les fêtes de fin d'année approchent et
il ne faudrait pas que festivités rime
avec accident pour alerter sur les
dangers de l'alcool au volant des
bénévoles de la prévention routière ont
distribué samedi des éthylotests dans un
centre commercial du chesnay il est
toujours obligatoire d'en disposer dans
les voitures la cible les jeunes dans
les jeunes c'est une majorité de
d'accidents sont dus à l'alcool
évidemment c'était un peu notre problème
des 18 27 ans dans la catégorie
d'achopper qui nous importe j'aime
beaucoup le slogan éclatez vous mais pas
sur la route
c'est tout à fait de circonstance pour
les fêtes en 2011 dans les yvelines sur
les 45 accidents mortels survenus 15
étaient liés à l'alcool depuis 2006
l'alcool est la première cause de
mortalité sur les routes devant la
vitesse chaque semaine près de 76
personnes meurent sur les routes de
france et parmi elles près de 23 paires
de la vie dans un accident lié à un abus
d'alcool